a star is born so a star is born stars
Lady Gaga and Bradley Cooper's directed
by Bradley Cooper Bradley Cooper plays a
famous musician he meets Lady Gaga's
character she writes music she has a
great voice but she's kind of shy she's
like I don't want to put myself out
there so during one of his concerts he
invites her on stage she crushes it so
from there the things build their
relationship builds her career starts
building and we're there front row seat
front and center to say it all the
performances are great - Bradley Cooper
crushes her it doesn't surprise me when
he does anymore dude is just top-notch
she's a great comedic actor he's a great
dramatic actor and he's great in this
movie also a great director came out the
gate swinging on this one Lady gaga
also great I love Lady Gaga's career I
just do you know sometimes when the
singer wants to be an actor and you're
like alright stick to sing and not the
case with Lady Gaga I'm glad she can
give us good music and good performances
she might get an Oscar nomination here I
don't know cuz I'm not good at
predicting Oscars also speaking of music
the music an alright I guess I'm now
going to jump on the hypothesising
Academy stuff that the music in here is
I really like the soundtrack if this
movie gets any oscar recognition
whatsoever music has to be part of that
conversation write a music itself was
just an array of emotions that I really
done but even the supporting cast
surprised me oh I see a few comics in
here a few comedians you might or will
recognize Dave Chappelle and Andrew Dice
Clay are both in this movie I didn't
recognize Andrew Dice Clay for the
longest time so I was like usually when
I see Andrew Dice Clay he looks like
that he looks like the 80s just sneezes
someone out in modern day it doesn't
look like that in this movie looks like
a normal dude plays Lady Gaga's father
he's not in the movie much but I thought
he was good for what he did same with
Dave Chappelle he's in like a scene in
the movie but for what he did I'm glad
that they're flexing their dramatic
muscles one of the other reasons I like
this movies people glamorize the fantasy
of dating a famous person yeah granted
dating this famous person actually helps
her out was professionally speaking but
one she wasn't looking for that but also
to just personally it's different this
movie does show that generally artists
they're damaged people it's not gonna be
the joyride you might expect doesn't
mean there's not love there doesn't mean
there's not passion there means there's
drama there and one of the great
takeaways from this movie that I
personally had is how it shows when you
rise in Fame and there are more moving
parts to that machine it's harder to
maintain the integrity of your vision
and voice I don't I just really like
that point is this movie hits a very
pleasing try
Fecteau if you want to see a movie about
a famous person who's a bit of a rack
who's in the wake of their fame you
haven't if you want to see movie about
someone who's starting to rise in fame
you have it if you want to see a movie
about a relationship between these two
people and all the drama that comes with
it you have it and all the laughs Joey
tears awkward moments oh really well
executed in those movies movies heavy
for sure it's just a heavy drama so
depending on your phase in life and
where you are you got to be in it for
that if you're like I'm not in the mood
for drama I want to see venom you should
probably see venom but if you want to
see a heavy messy yet beautiful love
story about love and fame will you have
a star is born this is one of my
favorite movies of the year if not one
of my favorite emotionally heavy movies
of the year what does it hit me and I
will say a star is born is awesome
tacular alright so what star is born
have you seen it what did you think
about it what's your favorite drama
about a relationship whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]